-Halloween´s coming up --
your family, I know,
takes it very seriously.
-Very seriously.
-And I just wanted --
We have some photos to show
how serious you are.
Full "Star Wars" theme --
that´s brilliant.
-Wait a minute, full "Star Wars"
until the last minute when
August said,
"You know what,
I want to be Darth Vader."
-Oh, really?
-And I went, "Sweetie,
we have a theme."
And he said, "I want to be
Darth Vader."
-Really?
What was he supposed to be?
-I don´t know, one of those
little guys from the movie.
-Oh, okay.
-You know, little,
cute little guys.
-Oh, cute little, like an Ewok?
-Like, yeah.
-Oh, okay.
Well, look, it still works.
You didn´t have to
ruin it for me.
[ Laughter ]
But then that was when you just
had one kid and that´s easy.
-Yeah.
-And now you fully --
now you got -- There´s five of
you, so they go "Incredibles."
Fantastic.
This is some Day of the Dead
stuff there.
-Yep!
-Look very good.
That -- look at you guys!
-That´s "Inside Out."
-"Inside Out" family photo.
-I was Joy.
-Yeah, that´s great.
-He was sadness, anger --
-Yeah.
-Can you figure it out?
-Yeah, he´s very good,
he´s very intense.
How´d you get his hair
like that?
That´s great.
-It´s amazing what we do.
We have a team
to put this together.
-Yeah. And do they --
Do you chose as a -- Do the five
of you chose together?
-We do, the kids
sort of determine.
Yeah, they -- they call it.
-Is there a spoiler alert
element to this or --
Can you tell me
what you´re gonna be?
-No, I can´t.
I can´t be the betrayer.
-Oh, you can´t tell us
what you´re gonna be.
-Oh, no, no, no,
I´m sworn to secrecy.
-Gotcha.
When do you guys lock it down?
When did you know
what you´re gonna be?
-Oh, we just locked it --
I´ll tell you,
Peter was pitching a few ideas,
which I liked better.
He wanted to be, can I say?
-You can say, what --
-He wanted to be
a bouquet of flowers.
-The whole family was a --
-The whole family,
each a different flower, which I
thought was so beautiful.
-Yeah, I think that´s a --
I think it´s a dud, yeah.
-August is like --
[ Laughter ]
"Ahh! Ahh! No."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he just shut that down.
-First of all, I just --
I feel like
as a bouquet of flower,
you guys have to sort of shuffle
down the street together.
-But we do anyway.
-Yeah.
I think as a kid --
how old´s August now?
-He´s 11.
-Yeah, so he´s like --
he wants to be able to
break away,
maybe at some point, you know.
-Yeah. I´m not ready!
-Especially if you shamed him
for the Darth Vader thing,
I´m sure he´s like,
"I don´t know."
-Well, it´s just that he´s
changing at the last minute.
Thank God I had
like four more outfits.
-But, like, everything´s
locked down and ready to go?
-No, it´s locked down.
We´re ready to go.
Usually, you know, beginning
of October, we´re good.
-All right, that´s great.
-Yeah, no, we prep.
-I also want to ask about this,
you are a "Hamilton" superfan
and a lot of people
would say that
they are the biggest fan of
"Hamilton,"
but you actually maybe have
a case to be made
that this is true.
You did the audiobook for Lin.
So Lin came to you. He knew that
you were intensely involved.
-He did.
-How many times did you see it?
-I´ve seen it 15 times.
-15 times!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That´s incredible.
-And I´m going again
because as you said in
the beginning of the show,
now, you know, we have guest
stars coming on the show.
-Yeah. Oh, so you take --
you like to take people.
-Well, no, but the guest star
is playing --
-Oh, of course!
-Right?
So they come on the show
and then I need to see them.
-Right.
-In it.
The new cast and they just blow
my mind.
-That was sort of one of
the famous things
about "Law and Order"
over the years
because it shoots in New York.
-Yeah.
-All the "Law and Orders" always
have fantastic Broadway actors.
-It is the greatest part
of my job.
-And that´s what you guys did
in 19 seasons,
so you could pay for 15 trips
to "Hamilton."
[ Laughter ]
-How do you think I did it?
Why do you think I´m gonna do it
for another two years?
-Exactly! And how was it
recording the audiobook?
Was it exciting?
-It was so exciting.
I had just finished directing
and I --
Actually, when he asked me,
I was just about to go into
directing and I was like,
"Ahh! How am I gonna do this?"
But when Lin calls you and says,
"Will you do the audiobook?"
you sort of --
I was so happy and I --
I sort of stayed up all night,
you know, rehearsing
and rereading
because you want to honor it.
-Yeah, of course.
-And I was --
So one of the great honors
of my life.
-Oh, well, that´s great.
-Truly.
-Well, congratulations.
-That´s so wonderful to hear.
And always such a honor
to have you here.
Thank you so much, Mariska.
-Thank you!